nouveau numéro de reporter plus le
magazine de reportage long format de
France 24 et c'est un portrait de femme
que nous vous proposons aujourd'hui
celui d'une congolaise née à Brazzaville
il y a 62 ans et qui a l'ambition de
faire bouger les choses sur le continent
grâce à l'éducation scientifique de haut
vol chercheuse spécialiste des maladies
infectieuses passer notamment par
l'Institut Pasteur à Paris Francine
Toumi n'a de 16 de transmettre et de
donner sa chance à la jeune génération
et particulièrement aux filles trop
souvent écartées des études
scientifiques pour cela elle n'hésite
pas à s'impliquer et à les convaincre
jusque dans la brousse c'est un document
de quête Thomson Gori et Michel veltord
[Musique]
je suis très contente d'être né au Congo
je suis très contente d'être une femme
je pense que c'est encore un atout parce
qu'il y a tellement à faire que l'on
peut encore initier commencer être celle
ou celui qui aura commencé à mettre en
place quelque chose
Francine Toumi est une scientifique
congolaise de renom sur diplômée
spécialiste du paludisme
[Musique]
son pays la République du Congo est
riche de ses 6 millions d'habitants de
son pétrole et de ses matières premières
mais ces infrastructures sont
défaillantes et 50% de la population vit
sous le seuil de pauvreté alors la
docteur en biologie moléculaire s'est
lancé un nouveau défi transformer le
Congo par l'éducation à la science et
s'adresser avant tout aux femmes aux
jeunes filles un message qu'elle a
décidé de porter à travers le pays
jeunes je me bats pour qu'il rêve
positifs de ce pays bon nos jeunes
idéalisent l'Europe en se disant que bon
peut-être que là-bas tout est plus
simple peut-être que là-bas ils auront
un toit peut-être que la base ils
pourront se faire soigner dans de bonnes
conditions donc moi je veux être
ambitieux pour mon pays je veux que mon
pays ressemble à un rêve ça veut dire
que je veux construire mon pays
tout est dit tout est dit
[Musique]
Brazzaville la ville natale de Francine
Touni c'est ici qu'elle a choisi de
revenir il y a plus de 10 ans elle a
interrompu sa carrière internationale
pour créer la Fondation congolaise pour
la Recherche Médicale le premier est
unique centre dédié à ces questions de
la République du Congo
[Musique]
au cœur de l'Afrique centrale le pays
est comme ses voisins massivement frappé
par les maladies infectieuses
paludisme Ébola choléra et covid qui a
lui aussi durement affecté le pays
[Musique]
ce laboratoire Ce
sont chefs de laboratoire et des jeunes
doctorants des jeunes Masters donc ça
reflète le pays le pays est à 70%
constitué de jeunes et là je suis fière
de pouvoir dire que ce sont ces jeunes
qui font de la recherche de qualité avec
beaucoup de sérieux et pour pouvoir se
préparer à la réponse aux épidémies de
maladies infectieuses
et c'est quel milieu
la scientifique a décidé d'embaucher une
majorité de femmes une exception car
dans le monde elle ne représente qu'un
tiers des chercheurs scientifiques et
seulement 10% en Afrique centrale
parmi elles une jeune doctorante qui
travaille aujourd'hui sur le covid
aujourd'hui
sont en train de vouloir regarder un
Goldman la persistance des anticorps et
des sujets infectés par sarscope 2 avant
de commencer l'envie d'abord faire la
durée notre solution de dilution et
aux échantillons de avant la covid et
après il est reparti dans la même
population après la covid voir s'il y
avait des réactions croisées d'anticorps
puisque on a entendu dire que peut-être
que la population africaine avait été
exposée à ce virus avant et cela nous a
permis de voir que le virus n'a pas été
du tout mis en évidence en tout cas dans
ces échantillons avant la pandémie de la
covid les lignes fait sa thèse elle va
soutenir l'année prochaine donc j'espère
que ça deviendra une grande je suis sûre
que ça deviendra une grande immunologie
j'avais un rêve mon rêve c'était d'être
médecin quand j'ai fait le concours de
l'INSA j'ai échoué au concours j'avais
perdu espoir je partais à la faculté de
sciences et techniques sans orientation
à l'époque je savais pas qu'une femme au
nom de Francine existait quelque part
quand j'ai remonté professeur Francine
c'était le premier jour du cours avec
elle j'étais épatée de la voir une femme
qui parlait ainsi avec assurance et à la
fin il fallait que je puisse me
rapprocher d'elle en disant madame je
vais être comme vous elle a cru au moins
elle m'a encouragé là je suis dans le
domaine de la science grâce à ses
motivations chaque jour je la prends
comme modèle par sa manière de faire
elle m'inspire beaucoup
Francine Toumi est un modèle que rien ne
prédestinait à avoir une telle carrière
une naissance au début des années 60
dans un quartier modeste de Brazzaville
une éducation stricte voire sévère et un
rôle de sœur aîné pour ses cinq petits
frères dont elle a souvent la charge
mais la Congolaise comprend vite que
c'est l'éducation qui lui permettra de
sortir de sa condition
je dirais mon père m'a transmise
l'ambition de donner le meilleur de
moi-même et aussi l'ambition de servir
les autres et j'ai perdu mon père une
semaine après avoir reçu ma première
récompense et l'une des plus importantes
la récompense de l'Union africaine donc
du continent sur mon travail
et un journaliste a posé la question à
mon père de quoi il était très fier et
mon père a répondu je suis évidemment je
suis très fière de Francine mais ma
crainte c'est que
elles prennent ses récompenses pour elle
qu'elle l'oublie de donner aux autres de
transmettre aux autres ce qu'est ce
qu'elle est en train de recevoir et plus
les années passent plus je comprends ce
qu'il a voulu dire donc c'est très
important pour moi cette transmission ça
fait partie de mon éducation certes mais
c'est au delà je pense que ça fait
partie ça doit faire partie de notre
humanité
elle est directrice de labo mais
professeur avant tout une transmission
qu'elle assure elle-même concrètement
lors de réunions hebdomadaires avec ses
étudiants
chaque semaine deux étudiants présentent
leur master et tout le monde commence
comme ça c'est l'occasion et prudence
pendant et c'est l'occasion de de
d'avoir la contribution de tout le monde
et surtout que chacun sache ce que
l'autre fait
ce sont des réunions dures ils se font
pas de cadeau et donc celui qui ou celle
qui présente c'est que ça va ça va être
ça fait
alors ils sont très très critiques et
tout le monde joue le jeu et évidemment
pour les nouveaux à la fin j'avertis ne
prenais pas mal les critiques de penser
pas ouh là là bon je suis nul ou bon
c'est le jeu c'est
[Musique]
le jeu voilà c'est
ça permet de présenter après le travail
le plus le plus abouti possible
[Musique]
et dans notre étude nous avons trouvé
que la concentration minimale de la
cuvette donnons les fils si Dieu
toxiques et donc le 0,25 dans le molaire
vu que la consommation donnant l'effet
si tout toxique maximale soit notre fils
est de en anomalie donc ce qui nous
intéresserait plus ici là c'est le cas
positif essentiellement
je sais pas si je suis en train de
juste
[Musique]
le tableau il faut mettre des légendes
en sciences c'est un travail de partage
partage de connaissances partage
d'expérience partage d'idées donc déjà
par nature faire de la recherche veut
dire vouloir partager et vouloir
transmettre parce que la toute petite
découverte fait aujourd'hui va
progresser pour donner quelque chose de
plus important 10 ans même 10 ans 20 ans
30 ans après donc j'essaie de créer une
équipe qui après puisse prendre le
relais et surtout que ces jeunes
s'épanouissent au Congo
[Applaudissements]
parmi les étudiants Christina c'est
doctorante est venu spécialement
d'Autriche pour profiter de l'expertise
en maladie infectieuses de la Fondation
alors que les pandémies sont aujourd'hui
globales les enseignements de sa
professeur ont une portée internationale
elle est l'une des principales femmes
scientifiques dans le domaine de la
recherche sur le paludisme qui est
également connu en Autriche en Allemagne
dans toute l'Europe dans la région de
l'Afrique centrale
et c'est unique je dirais pour une femme
d'être aussi largement reconnue dans son
domaine de recherche scientifique
la recherche n'est pas que dans un sens
du sens du Nord vers le Sud la
connaissance aussi va du Sud vers le
Nord et c'est beau de voir ces jeunes
justement aller dans les deux directions
en 2014 après avoir fondé le Centre de
Recherche Médicale Francine Toumi décide
de s'adresser au plus grand nombre elle
lance une grande campagne de
sensibilisation à la science son thème
la femme au cœur du savoir s'affiche
déjà partout dans la capitale
dans quelques jours la scientifique
participera à une grande première au
Congo une caravane sillonnera tout le
pays pour porter son message
[Musique]
c'est la veille du départ de la caravane
pour préparer sa campagne la docteur en
sciences s'est entouré d'une équipe
dynamique et surtout bien sapé alors
aujourd'hui nous sommes lundi et c'est
un jour que nous avons choisi pour
essayer d'être un peu plus élégant que
les autres jours Brazzaville c'est en
guillemets la ville de la sape
c'est-à-dire la société des ambiances et
des personnes élégantes c'est pourquoi
ce matin je me suis permis moi également
d'être un peu élégant donc c'est un
mouvement créé au Congo Brazzaville au
sortir des indépendances c'est-à-dire
des gens qui étaient en Europe après la
Première Guerre mondiale quand ils sont
revenus au pays ils avaient un style
vestimentaire on ne peut plus
exceptionnel personnellement je suis
habillé en veste queue de poule chapeau
pied de poule et puis j'ai eu votre
classique l'harmonie l'alchimie des
couleurs et bien respectée et si vous
allez plus bas j'ai une chaussure en
croco qui se marie avec le tissu
de ma tenue donc ces deux-là les
présente la maquette de
du véhicule décoré ensuite les
différents points d'action quand on va
aller sur le terrain c'est les prépas de
dernière minute et je suis en charge de
tout ce qui est communication autour de
la caravane notamment
la voiture qui est un élément clé pour
cette caravane parce qu'elle sera
habillée avec
la fiche de la campagne actuelle de des
femmes ici de femmes et sciences et le
thème de cette campagne c'est un projet
très ambitieux parce que
l'idée derrière c'est de conquérir tous
les cœurs
féminins en particulier
toutes les populations en général
congolaises c'est très angoissant de
préparer cette caravane parce que ça va
être une première il y a pas mal de
choses à avoir à préparer avant d'aller
sur le terrain et nous voulons aller
vers la réussite de ce challenge llenge
l'équipe de Francine compte une dizaine
de personnes mais c'est bien elle qui
supervise tout jusque dans les moindres
détails
l'autorisation pour aller entre là et
après on a vu le chef du village comme
ça il va faire le relais d'information
auprès des habitants du village
nous nous sommes jusqu'ici focaliser
dans les grandes villes et là maintenant
grâce à cette caravane nous allons aller
dans le Congo profond et de nous rendre
dans des lieux où il ne jusqu'ici il
nous était difficile de nous rendre par
rapport à la logistique nécessaire la
campagne mobile de femmes et comme nous
allons dans des contrées un peu éloignés
ça permet aussi de sensibiliser sur
que ça va interpeller les gens et c'est
ce qu'on veut
sa carrière de scientifique elle ne l'a
pas commencé au Congo mais en France à
l'Institut Pasteur de Paris elle
travaille ensuite au Gabon en Allemagne
puisant Tanzanie en 2016 elle reçoit le
trait prestigieux prix Merieux pour ses
travaux de recherche sur les maladies
infectieuses en Afrique centrale
[Musique]
elle est aussi nommée dans de nombreux
comités scientifiques internationaux
notamment au sein de la Fondation Bill
et Melinda Gates
quand petite congolaise on reçoit une
invitation de Bill Gates qui des cheveux
que vous soyez dans mon comité ce qui me
donne des conseils sur comment je dois
interagir dans le Global F pour moi ça
c'est la reconnaissance de mes pères
enfin en 2022 c'est la consécration elle
intègre la célèbre académie mondiale des
sciences
mais un jour j'étais dans le management
de la recherche et dans toutes les
réunions l'Afrique centrale était
pointée du doigt il y avait passé de
scientifique passer le publication nous
étions vraiment les derniers du peloton
et je vous assure que quand on est
d'Afrique centrale soi-même et que l'on
entend dire cela en se demande tout
simplement est-ce que je suis à ma place
autour de cette table ou est-ce que je
ne devrais pas être au pays et puis
travailler parce que c'est tellement
facile quand on est loin de critiquer et
de donner des leçons aux autres qui sont
sur place de leur dire il suffit de et
je voulais pas être quelqu'un qui dise
il suffit de je vous les faire et
j'ai pris la décision d'organiser mon
retour au Congo
pour l'événement qu'elle prépare
Francine Toumi a fait venir son fils
d'Allemagne il est devenu son bras droit
on avait fait un grand barbecue avec un
groupe de musique etc et puis se l'idée
c'était ça je suis pas fan de voir vos
visages dans notre vie grand mais bon
depuis ma personne l'a enlevé donc je
crois que ça va rester ici
sur ma mère et moi on est deux personnes
extrêmement foncièrement différente je
suis extrêmement extraverti et j'aime
bien lui montrer j'adore être être
présent parler je parle beaucoup et
j'aime j'aime sortir et j'aime j'aime
communiquer à tous les niveaux et ma
mère c'est quelqu'un de très introverti
si elle peut rester seule elle va rester
seule je suis beaucoup plus chaotique je
suis beaucoup plus spontanée et elle est
elle peut aussi manquer de flexibilité
et moi je suis tout en flexibilité donc
ça crée aussi à ce niveau là des fois
beaucoup de clashs de tension même si on
essaye de se rapprocher et maintenant
qu'on travaille ensemble c'est c'est pas
toujours
simple il faut oui
il faut il faut garder en fait
ironiquement il faut garder ses
distances
nous sommes à la veille du départ stylis
reconnu Jean Cédric emmène sa mère au
marché local pour choisir les tissus
avec lesquels il confectionnera lui-même
les futurs tenues de Francine on y va on
y va si on attend vers ça
[Musique]
le travail de ma mère est absolument
humain je pense que elle aurait pu avoir
beaucoup d'autres carrières mais elle
s'est dédiée à son pays au final grâce à
ça au monde c'est vrai que elle elle est
très axée sur la femme mais je trouve
que de nos jours on a un certain niveau
tout le monde peut nous inspirer et à
l'inspirer énormément de gens notamment
moi
[Musique]
et ça c'est cool
c'est le grand jour la caravane va
partir dans quelques heures
c'est la pièce maîtresse une jeep aux
couleurs de la scientifique a été
terminée juste à temps alors le véhicule
est juste là à côté de vous avec la
fiche de la campagne de cette année la
femme au cœur du savoir on a eu vraiment
peur de rater le branding du véhicule
pour la caravane qui débute aujourd'hui
du coup on a travaillé toute la nuit et
on a fini à 4 heures 10
extrêmement épuisé mais bon pour les
raisons de la cause en ce sacrifie
comme pour toi parce que c'était tout un
marathon et puis on disait qu'on était
des challengers on a bien voulu aller au
bout du challenge et puis voilà le
résultat qui se trouve d'abord
c'est le plus important
donc je crois que on est prêt pour le
début de la cave
c'est comme le puzzle
et donc
pour retrouver la ah oui c'est même ah
oui
on voit là c'est micro pour forfait ça
permet de voir de l'intérieur de
l'extérieur et bébé
ça pour faire la pub ça sera la plus
la femme au cœur du savoir on va bien le
savoir
il y a le matériel qui va d'abord être
installé ce matin et à 17h quand vous
arrivez on lance
la projection du film le jour où je vais
me lancer en politique
je serai déjà rodée au palais les
véhicules
parce que là c'est un peu les prémices
non c'est un peu ça c'est rigolo
on n'y avait pas pensé au début mais
c'est vrai que ça fait une campagne
mobile c'est pas c'est pas mal
surtout que il y en a pas beaucoup de
donc ça va ça va intriguer et donc ça va
obliger les gens à lire et
c'est bien ok à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
premier objectif les zones les plus
rurales du Congo les plus pauvres aussi
en dehors de Brazzaville la plupart des
villages n'ont accès ni à l'eau ni à
l'électricité
la population y est très jeune près de
la moitié à moins de 18 ans
[Musique]
j'espère nous arrivons dans le village
de Tulla à quelques heures de route au
sud de la capitale pour parler sciences
c'est Francine to me qui prend la parole
bonsoir
moi je suis maman Francine
et merci de m'accueillir chez vous ce
soir
nous allons suivre le film et puis nous
allons parler après nous allons demander
à la technique
d'un projet de fil
[Musique]
[Rires]
mais au moment de lancer le film les
choses se compliquent
l'électricité donc il a fallu
transporter l'électricité donc avec un
groupe électrogène et il y a toujours
des petits couacs
pas de son alors c'est là débrouille
Steve comment et traduit le film en
direct
là elle explique les caractères de sa
fille comment est-ce qu'elle a élevé
comment est-ce qu'elle est devenue
scientifique
les enfants les papa et les mamans si
quelqu'un peut déposer une question le
micro est là moi je t'ai pas à l'école
mais ça m'a impressionné si vous
continuez que à des actes comme ça notre
pays aura honneur au nord à des choses
comme ça
aller à l'école les mamans aussi doivent
faire et les papas doivent faire de ton
mieux pour encourager leurs enfants
quand tu es conviés à l'école toi tu es
le premier à l'école
c'est une fille ou un garçon
tu es le premier à l'école
[Musique]
la distance paraît loin entre ses
laboratoires et puis cet endroit mais en
fait il était pour moi important de leur
rappeler que cet endroit n'est pas si
loin parce que je viens exactement du
même endroit et que j'ai pu
par l'école justement arriver là où je
suis et probable et j'espère continuer à
me développer donc c'était important
d'apporter ce message parce que c'est un
message vrai qui correspond à la réalité
tous ces petits-enfants peuvent un jour
devenir de grands scientifiques et des
grands responsables de ce pays il suffit
que voilà qu'on les écoles donne
l'éducation nécessaire
[Musique]
retour à Brazza le surlendemain
c'est l'heure du débriefing et le temps
de Francine Toumi se fait plus sec je
vous écoute mais il y a eu un souci avec
le direct c'est que le modem que nous
avons utilisé c'est le modèle de la FCN
toutes les personnes dans la FCM était
connecté et la bande ne suffisait plus
pour poursuivre le direct jusqu'à la fin
on avait déjà envisagé la possibilité
d'avoir un problème avec un modèle d'où
il fallait partir avec de vous partez
avec un et vous dites comme une fleur en
madame etc moi je trouve ça
insupportable ça ça m'agace
[Musique]
j'ai eu envie de laisser tomber pourquoi
je me prends la tête
à faire du à devenir entrepreneur ce qui
n'est pas mon job quand je peux faire ma
science tranquillement
en Allemagne mes collègues
ils se lèvent le matin
il pense quelque chose faire leur job
n'hésitez scientifiques du bois il
ils ont des idées comment développer
leurs idées moi je me lève
comment résoudre le problème d'eau là
comme
je veux dire comment il y a plus d'eau
dans la bâche à eau alors on peut pas
faire des manies appelez le camion mais
la société a fermé alors qu'il peut nous
on peut trouver de l'eau et donc on va
passer deux heures à résoudre ce
problème
merci je vous remercie pour tous vos
efforts et puis maintenant c'est il y a
le phoque le suivi de tout ça à la fin
de l'année en Allemagne je suis évalue
au même titre que mes collègues qui eux
n'avaient qu'une seule chose à penser et
mais c'est très bien je me plains pas
parce qu'on a d'excellents résultats
même comparer donc ça montre que le
potentiel est là qu'on peut faire
beaucoup plus
quand tu vois le regard de mes étudiants
ils comme garçon moi ils ont tous cette
même énergie veulent réussir maintenant
ils font de la compétition pour les
publications bon ça me fait plaisir donc
quand tu
tu vois le regard du dise si je laisse
tomber mais qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce
qu'ils vont devoir
je peux pas
[Musique]
depuis son indépendance en 1960 la
République du Congo a connu de nombreux
conflits dont le pays ne s'est pas
encore remis
notamment les deux ans de guerre civile
à la fin des années 90 qui ont fait plus
de 25000 morts et 250 000 déplacés
le contexte complexe du poste
colonialiste de la crise humanitaire et
de l'urgence climatique fait que le pays
est encore aujourd'hui un chantier
permanent sur le chemin du développement
et de la démocratie
même dans la capitale beaucoup reste à
faire et Francine to me veut pas
négliger les jeunes populations
plusieurs bennes
chez sa tante dans le quartier de son
enfance là où tout a commencé
[Musique]
comment vas-tu
à la maison
la nouvelle campagne
qu'est-ce que je voulais faire moi je
ferai la médecine
[Musique]
c'est la science
tu aimes ce métier
qu'est-ce qu'il vous intéresse on parle
métier les femmes et les sciences ça
vous dit quoi
et les hommes et les sciences alors
je parle hein
chirurgien c'est passé
[Rires]
une petite erreur ça arrive dans l'eau
bien sûr
plutôt bien scolarisé jusqu'à leur 16
ans les filles décrochent souvent
ensuite malgré leur ambition de départ
[Musique]
les enfants qui travaillent bien à
l'école le métier rêvé et d'être médecin
et pour les enfants et pour les parents
donc il y a que seul métier important au
Congo c'est la réussite signifie de
venir médecin c'est très marrant ça il y
a pas de le panel de choix n'est pas là
en terme d'imagination et de rêve et
c'est là où c'est important
d'élargir le champ des rêves des enfants
et des parents parce que c'est
incroyable c'est incroyable et tous
garçons et filles voulaient être médecin
il y a qu'une qui voulait devenir
avocate et ou journaliste et un garçon
entrepreneur voilà tous les autres
médecins
il y en a même une qui a dit qui a été
expressé qu'elle veut servir elle veut
soigner elle veut servir les autres ça
c'est très intéressant
elle est en troisième et elle va être
médecin pour servir c'est beau
l'accès à l'éducation des femmes est un
enjeu majeur au Congo mais il passe
aussi par d'autres droits fondamentaux
comme la santé reproductive
la mortalité maternelle est très
importante ici 33 décès pour 1000
naissances
dans les faubourgs de Brazza la
Fondation Mérieux a confié à Francine la
construction d'une maternité moderne
ment
au travail alors si je me pose c'est qui
qu'est-ce que je vais les expliquer ils
nous disent vous êtes je dis c'est le
docteur oui après
on va on va jeter un coup d'œil
ok super
nous avons le gynécologue qui est là les
femmes viennent elles sont suivies mais
seulement qu'elle accouche pas chez nous
mais à partir de ce que nous sommes en
train de le faire elles accoucheront
maintenant ici donc je pense déjà que ça
c'est un vœu qui se réalise pour elle
mais maman qui est celle qui a tout
compte les la famille
[Musique]
de passer de l'autre côté ok super
80% des décès maternels pourrait être
évitées si les femmes avaient accès à
des soins de qualité ainsi que soit
obstétrique d'urgence
en fait
ça viendra bientôt voilà un peu vraiment
ça c'est vraiment un bijou un bijoux
maternité dans le quartier de matissia
qui est un quartier populaire et c'est
la seule maternité le médecin là donc
c'est la seule maternité digne de ce nom
dans après le point de vue en terme de
qualité
c'est un beau défi on va voir
parce qu'évidemment au début les gens
auront peur de venir parce qu'ils vont
se dire c'est cher c'est vrai que j'ai
un peu peur quand même c'est un peu
beaucoup ça me paraît un peu grand pour
moi quand même c'est
vrai c'est encore une autre dimension
j'avais jamais prévu avoir ce type de
responsabilité là aussi voilà
tu peux pas dire non moi quand la
Fondation merveilleuse dit bon on vous
construit une maternité c'est pas normal
que les femmes ne puissent pas accoucher
on peut pas dire non on dit oui bon
[Applaudissements]
ce soir un grand événement se prépare
Francine Toumi doit remettre des bourses
à 8 élèves de Master pour financer leurs
études mais la pluie menace la soirée
donc avec la cérémonie de remise des
bourses les filles sont tellement
impatientes je suis impatiente alors on
scrute le ciel et
[Musique]
c'est bon le public est au rendez-vous
tu vas rentrer dans le National les
députés machin les secrétaires je sais
pas trop de quoi là
mon dieu c'est tout ce que
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pomme et science est un programme qui
encourage les jeunes filles à travailler
pour la science au service de la paix
dans le monde
j'invite le professeur Francine soumis
président de la Fondation congolaise
pour la recherche médicale à nous parler
du thème de la campagne femme et
sciences de cette année sur vos
applaudissements
[Applaudissements]
je suis vraiment très heureuse de vous
voir si nombreux et vous me voyez là
très ému merci vraiment d'être là
l'histoire de l'humanité nous apprend
que plusieurs femmes ont été
volontairement oubliés lors de certaines
récompenses je pense par exemple au prix
Nobel pour lequel plusieurs hommes se
sont appropriés sans aucun scrupule des
travaux réalisés et portés par les
femmes c'est ce qu'on appelle l'effet
Matilda nous avons la lourde
responsabilité de faire en sorte que ce
phénomène malsain ne se répète plus les
loriotes d'aujourd'hui sont des jeunes
filles pleines d'ambition qui rêvent de
transformer leur environnement et de
construire un Congo plus beau et un
Congo meilleur nous allons mettre la
lumière sur ces jeunes femmes afin
qu'elles deviennent des rôles modèles
pour d'autres jeunes de leur génération
et de la génération d'après c'est notre
façon de contribuer au changement de
paradigme que nous appelons de tous nos
vœux
[Musique]
la caravane est repartie et se dirige
vers l'un des trésors du Congo ces
forêts tropicales toujours préservées un
sanctuaire de gorille au cœur de la
jungle
[Musique]
bonjour
sur la route la caravane s'arrête pour
acheter une spécialité de la brousse
au village ça me rappelle tout ça et je
suis très satisfait d'en avoir
moins de 20 minutes
[Musique]
pourquoi parce que je sais pas nager toi
aussi tu sais pas nager tu as peur de
l'eau alors
ça je n'aime pas beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de l'eau si je tombe là c'est
fini je veux me noyer
la scientifique congolaise dirige le
réseau Pandora qui regroupe 13 pays et
23 institutions en Europe et en Afrique
elle a réuni de nombreux professionnels
de la santé publique et de
l'environnement pour unir leurs forces
et anticiper de futurs pandémies
[Musique]
les voyages à l'époque de l'Afrique à la
mairie cela pouvait prendre des mois
aujourd'hui c'est quelques heures donc
tout va très vite et les virus qui
étaient enfermés on va dire comme ça
dans la forêt dans un écosystème bien
particulier contenu le fait d'ouvrir les
routes ouvraient aussi les routes au
virus donc on peut s'attendre à de
nouveaux virus qui infectent l'homme
peut-être de manière plus ou moins
dangereuse plus ou moins efficaces et là
la science doit
travailler pour pouvoir les détecter au
plus tôt et pouvoir les contrôler les
contenir les éliminer le plus tôt
possible
il reste encore parce qu'il va foncer de
l'autre côté ah non il mange encore
est-ce que ça fait du bien d'être sur le
terrain on a besoin sur les terrains tu
vas prendre beaucoup plus en pratiquant
que on reste sur place en attendant les
échantillons au labo on va compter sur
le terrain tu connais la réalité toutes
les contours de ton étude tu connais tu
maîtrises correctement tu participes à
tout pour bien voir après comment mettre
en perspective comment analyser les
échantillons tenant compte de ce qui se
passe chez l'animal qui vit à côté de
voilà des individus qui sont prélevés
les gorilles en particulier les
Françaises bon passons là ils sont
protégés évidemment dans la protection
il faut il y a des infections qui
passent de l'homme à l'animal et par
exemple pour la conduite avant d'aller
voir les grands singes il fallait
s'assurer que aucun individu n'est
affecté ni les soignants ni les
visiteurs donc
dans le cas de leur protection il faut
s'assurer que bon on ne leur on ne les
contamine pas comme eux aussi nous
contaminent pas
si la branche se casse et qui tombe à
l'eau comment il va puisqu'ils n'aiment
pas l'eau il peut nager un peu non pas
du tout hein
non plus il fait son malin là
il se la joue
ouais moi je m'assie sur ma branche
[Musique]
je voudrais avoir
aplanir le chemin pour celles qui
arrivent derrière si je m'étais résigné
on n'aurait pas eu de tels résultats
j'espère qu'elle voit aller
des résultats 10 fois 100 fois meilleurs
que les miens c'est vraiment ce que je
souhaite
la caravane va continuer sa route et
sillonner le Congo pendant toute une
année aller à la rencontre des
populations congolaises les sensibiliser
permettre aux jeunes femmes d'accéder à
la science voilà l'ambition de la
professeur Francine Toumi et ce n'est
peut-être pas la seule
[Musique]
reportage de Kate Thompson gorille et
Michel velterlin c'est la fin de ce
magazine merci de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de reporter sur France 24
[Musique]